my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah
what do you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with the baked beans sometimes with
baked beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please
[Music]
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be good right now
sausages
are getting lots of color because this
is going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one nani's
to make for me yeah once you've got the
color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
packed with flavor
that's kind of nice nice mushrooms in
give them a nice little stir
did you like to help them make your hot
pot when she made them for you i used to
always help them make the hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
her onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss i'm going to put my sausages back
in here now from there
some red wine
red wine end
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look pretty cool
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven
170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot greton are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
is this thanks for the warning
you're both so well only blew my head
off
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called brae burns what other apples do
you know green ones what they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no
red no
pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're gonna do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambley cooking apple with the
sweetness of the braeburn get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger
and three little cinnamon sticks i want
you to remember that because we're gonna
look for them
okay because once we've used them and
they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay
and then
the place
doesn't it
give that
a nice
little
toss
okay nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
and we go into there what's that coming
out dab so that is a little bit of the
puree i'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with the cinnamon
we've got other ginger gingers i'm gonna
take
a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in they're
great separate
off
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff peak so you lift them
up
now that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butterscotch now to make the cream even
lighter fold in those whisked egg whites
and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that
in so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
is that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with the flat leaf parsley
wow look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel-good factor
the perfect side dish for my fantastic
fried chicken
jack
hi my gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it i like pickled onions we're
gonna do pickled celery mm-hmm it's a
nice little snack and great for planned
ones great for salads first thing i'm
going to pick the celery for me so you
see where the next one's going to be
it's in there yeah okay i'll figure it
out but i'm hungry today is this all
we're having for dinner jack come on i
wouldn't do that too you know that
there's more coming now because we're
pickling it
we want to sort of make it
look
a little bit more attractive so we go
around with that okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavor yeah okay now splash of
water and then with the sugar nice okay
so we've got to bring that up to the
bowl
and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now touch of salt no
okay
so from there white wine vinegar
now
in order for all that to actually
pickle
you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together infuses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest
yes it was good look boom it's working
already now see
nice wine vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball now
turn that off
now
from there
start placing the celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off mm-hmm okay now put them in there so
can we eat this straight away when it's
in here do you know what as soon as it's
cooled down
you can definitely eat that straight
away i can't wait to dig into it at
dinner are they delicious yes we'll
leave that to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken on fried chicken
traditionally it's always gonna be done
with the dark meat the brown meat so you
got that nice sort of uh drum
here and this bit
that thigh cooking on the bone as well
keeps it even more moist so first things
first salt pepper please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken if you can put this
buttermilk over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax
the chicken and puts a really nice sort
of creamy soury flavor in there so might
stick that in the fridge for us please
and we'll start the dolce de leche
biscuits nice
the argentinians call these shortbreads
alfa jorge and they're the favorite
sweet treat on the streets of buenos
aires
they're light crumbly shortbread
biscuits sandwich with gloriously golden
caramelly dolce de leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots scrape out the seeds
add to the mix
and beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour
corn flour
and baking powder
then fold the mixture together
using floured hands roll into small
balls
flatten into discs and place on a baking
tray
[Music]
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled
sandwich two biscuits together with a
caramelly dolce de leche sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it
now we're gonna
roll the chicken out of the buttermilk
into the flour so that's why it gets
nice and crispy and blistery on the
outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yeah
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
making it yeah yeah spice that's right a
little bit of heat and this one my
favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimetres of oil this is a really
good mix for fish as well mm-hmm
gushon's fighting
a nice spicy
texture
helps fish
so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down yes okay really
important to get them covered completely
okay
in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do you
now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there
or turn off the gas
good gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah
now
off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
sell them
oh nice
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you pretty
sure i love it morning look here's the
best bite
delicious now
fried chicken
and pickles if you pick up um dolce de
leche cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's good
delicious mummy wow tilly phoebe rum
divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken a soulful street food feast if
there ever was one
mouth watering smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
that's away
butts away
now this is incredible there's the
shoulder yeah and look there's the
shoulder blade if you go through here
there's a knuckle there that's
connecting the top and that's why
it's called a butt
the slower you cook it the more juicy it
is and it's great for big parties
because you just come along and get your
fork and shred it a delicious smoky
mayonnaise and you're away onions into
half and half again okay i'm gonna leave
the roots on okay because i want this to
sit underneath the port
it gives it a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now i'll peel the garlic
okay i'd like you
to crush the garlic we're gonna make a
really nice little paste
okay
go on maggie
come on come on come on
nice good girl one more
crush
come on maggie i'm coming
sorry about that
little
cup there now this
is a beauty
paprika smoked paprika i love it so
three nice tablespoons in
okay
two
large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please and pepper could go
[Laughter]
so gonna form a nice paste now
olive oil in
mix that some thyme in there
so we've got a sort of fragrant rub
time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now
this is where you've got to be really
quick
okay
and sort of rub that mushroom in almost
exactly that
smells amazing honestly you just drizzle
a little touch of olive oil on top of
that for me
i keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinading the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if i was
doing this for a sunday and start
marinating thursday friday so it gets
even tastier right quite easy as well to
make it's very easy five and a half to
six hours in the oven
at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts meg
and i are gonna pimp some shot-bought
mayonnaise
i don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you can twist
about yeah there's so many things so
many exciting things you can do with it
right
salt
pepper
and
little touch of honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and i've got a little bit of
you know this chipotle smoked chipotle
paste i love that once you've made this
dressing
you know it can sit in the fridge
great for open sandwiches yeah can you
use it for any sandwiches really any
sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
i've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so
that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites
first deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finely dye sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and grate some nutty grilled cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
[Music]
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling of grated
greer
these simple cheesy crushed potatoes are
equally delicious served hot or cold
now i want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
i'm gonna make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli
okay the bit that everybody wants once
they're off i'm gonna slice the broccoli
okay mm-hmm never had raw broccoli
before it's always been cooked really
when you dress this with the dressing
it's incredible
now
a little seasoning early on
yeah okay now for the dressing
fresh yogurt in teaspoon of sugar please
daddy
a little smell
cider vinegar mmm there you go
finely chopped [ __ ] hot
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
i love them that gives that nice sort of
chewy texture all right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please
thank you
and stop and then mix that up with me
good girl
i will taste
so good and it's the kind of salad it
doesn't wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the broccoli
is raw
raw broccoli salad
chipotle now let me be the poor cow with
this look at this megan honestly
that
is amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now
that goes to the table like that i
deliberately have a tiny bit just before
we go to the table
just a little bit honestly meg
don't tell mom thank you honestly
do i do it i'm gonna do it
man it's incredible so good you promised
me you don't give the recipe to your
boyfriend let's go
come on
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
and quick simple sides of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw
deliciously yummy dishes that will have
your family friends and work buddies
coming back for more
you